I think that,
um,
it's more of a great philosophy that you
have a Moira,
you have a lot in life,
and aristotle taught us that you take
your Moyer,
you kind of realize where it is.
Can you try to fill it up as much as you
can?
Aristotle also taught a very good lesson
that people like naturally there's
something inherent in human beings about
wanting to perfect whatever you do,
you need tries to understand why this
is.
But yeah,
it doesn't get added.
But he says it's clear.
People like to perfect what they do.
Then the second is far more even more
insightful.
And that is people like to perfect
complicated subjects more than easy
subjects.
So in a very simple analogy,
no one becomes a fanatic on checkers.
I've never seen somebody say,
oh my God,
I love checkers.
I just think of checkers all the time.
It's a simple game.
Uh,
but chess,
you find lots of fanatics in chess,
their whole life revolves around chest.
Why?
Because just as complicated and so they
to perfect,
it takes a lot of effort.
So I think that there is a great
attraction to taking something hard like
Shakespeare or like understanding the
arts and try to perfect that rather than
takes up the simple and perfecting that.
That's why a musicians are so stretched
because,
uh,
you know,
it's very hard to be a very good mood.
Just anybody in the arts is stress a
lot.
Stretch a lot because it's complicated
and that's,
aristotle would tell you that's what
makes it so much fun and it makes it
very frustrating because a,
there's not much margin for error there.